hecker de tpm paix qu'on piégée une
seule personne sur des fringues à votre
avis tu gilou cette chemise il a pas mis
tout seul il savait pas mais en fait ils
étaient filmés changé c'est le seul truc
tout le monde en parle le seul doute
chez what qui va vraiment pas c'est le
stylisme cyril pourquoi il fait jamais
failli du moins beaucoup moins mais
pourquoi il fait jeunes pareil des
femmes c'est hyper important
ça ça dingue tiens ça comme on ne pourra
rien faire sur la tronche à redon sur le
lac avec elle et je lui c'est chiant ce
que c'est surtout visible est déjà bien
mais là c'est très bien est-ce que je
peux me permettre
la paire touche pour être à la mode
aujourd'hui c'est tout beaux tout bios
il se fait je veux faire de toi world
appartient au visage se faire sauter tu
rigoles baby come back que ça c'est
stylé en pour les gars c'est mon choix
moi on verra
moi je vous dis que series va adorer
l'hyper days trouvait pas sa boîte c'est
dégueulasse